[Music]
[Applause]
he's Jay bis the 13th annual State Farm
Champions classic returns tonight it's
Duke Michigan State and then uh it'll be
Kansas and uh Kentucky that'll be at the
United Center in Chicago and Jay will be
working with Dan scholman and Hol ow
good to see you before I get to
basketball you being a lawyer I want you
to repres presentent Michigan and Jim
Harbaugh in this situation that's going
on with the big
10 it's primarily Dan a du process
argument uh I don't think they're going
to get to the merits of of what happened
uh and exactly what evidence the Big 10
may have it's a question of did the big
clan follow its rules and did Michigan
get due process of a hearing and to
present their evidence before a
punishment was handed down I I haven't
read the Big 10 bylaws I don't know what
their sportsmanship ship you know this
this is all under the egis or the
umbrella of sportsmanship policy I don't
know what it says uh but I think it's a
little bit of an uphill climb for
Michigan here and uh and I think the Big
10 is probably going to wind up having
the authority to to ultimately do what
it did is there cheating in basketball I
mean this is sign stealing I don't know
and we had the Astros in baseball is
there anything that is still nefarious
with college basketball given that you
have nil transfer portal not that I'm
aware of I mean there's always been you
know players being paid and all that
stuff that's that's sort of outside uh
the rulebook and nobody even knows what
the rulebook is right now with nil that
the players are not supposed to be paid
for play but that everybody who had any
brain in their head knew that's what nil
was going to be um but I I don't know of
any you know there's no in-person
scouting for basketball um I know
there's a lot of information Shar in so
if uh you know if I've Got a Friend say
I'm on the staff at Dayton i' and we're
playing uh you know George Washington
and I've got a friend on another staff
who just played George Washington I know
there's sharing of scouting reports but
I don't think that there's anything
nefarious about that I think the problem
for Michigan here was the the violation
of The in-person Scouting Rule and you
know it used to be in basketball
football you could go to opponent's
games and have advanced scouting in
person but they got rid of that I think
more for cost than anything all right uh
what should we be looking for tonight
with this double
header you know four of the preseason
best teams in the country I think the
lowest rated team was 16th and that's
Kentucky um you know in the first game
Michigan state has not played well and H
they're a veteran team that went to the
Sweet 16 last year and they've got four
out of their five starters back the only
one gone is Joey Hower and uh I think
they're two of 31 in their first two
games from three uh they've been out
rebounded uh they have not looked the
part of of a Michigan State team uh I
tend to think that that's going to
change tonight and it better um you know
Duke just came off a loss against
Arizona in a heavyweight fight in
Cameron Indoor Stadium it was so great
to see that kind of game this early in
the season and you can tell that Tommy
Lloyd of Arizona and John shy of Duke
you know want to play those type of game
and test their teams um and Duke's got
some adjustments to make uh they got
outrebounded badly uh against uh Arizona
and uh and Arizona kind of exposed that
uh that you know shot makers at the four
position you know they can lay off the
fourman and clog the lane so Duke's
going to have to adjust to that best Pro
Prospect in the building tonight will be
who you know I think there are about 15
guys off these four rosters that are
going to play in the NBA uh I think
Jonathan gavon projected seven are going
to be taken in the first round this year
in the draft if they were to come out uh
if probably between I'd say Justin
Edwards at Kentucky The Freshman or the
sophomore Kyle filipowski at Duke um
they're they're you know they're very
different players but ky's got kind of a
I don't want to say old school but um
it's it's John caliper going back to hey
we're getting the best freshman and
we're gonna we're gonna develop talent
and at the end of the year we're going
to be really good but we're going to be
really young at the beginning and bring
him along he he did the transfer thing
the last couple years and it didn't work
out quite the way they weren't as
talented but older and I think he's gone
back to the no I want I want super
talent and they've got super Talent this
year the three-point shot and how
important it is um these coaches when
they go out recruiting like how
important is it that they're they're
looking for that three-point shooter and
and like where is that at the priority
list of bringing in these players it's
pretty high uh it's not quite NBA High
uh because I think you know you've
noticed this because you know basketball
so well but there are so many low poost
big guys in the country right now that
are among the best players they're not
as coveted in the NBA so they're staying
a school longer whether it's Zach Edy uh
Ryan cauler at uh at kraton um you know
you Hunter Dickinson at uh at Kansas you
name it and years ago those guys would
have all been gone but now they're
coming back one they can make a lot of
money in college but uh but they're not
first round draft picks like they've
been in the past I think if you can
stretch it uh you're way more valuable
but uh you know you still need Rim
protection and that's one thing Kentucky
has it but they got their Rim protectors
are hurt right now so they're playing
kind of a smaller lineup five out and I
think that'll change when their big guys
come back he's Jay bis he'll be on the
call with Dan shman in Holly Road
tonight it's a double header on the
mothership Duke Michigan State followed
by Kentucky and Kansas when we look back
on loyal to marmount were they ahead of
everybody with what is today's like it
was it a different style with l you know
uh we're going to take the three we're
going to give you the two and we're just
going to run you all night long a little
bit yeah um Paul westad who I had a kind
of a connection to um I went to high
school with his daughters Monica and
Patrice at Rolling Hills High School in
California and I also played with Jack
McKenna's son John uh when he fell off
the bike and all that stuff happened
with the showtime Lakers right around
1980 81 give or take when I was a
sophomore junior in high school and I
think when when West head got kind of
bounced around a little bit um you know
it seemed like he said okay you want to
you want me to play fast I'm G to play
fast and I remember looking at uh I was
an assistant Grand assistant at Duke at
the time and I remember looking at like
press guys of opponents and everybody
had their career high against loyal and
Marry m everybody if they played him
that was every player's career high
because the scores were up in the 120s
and one sometimes
130 um but yeah they ran and and you
know defense was not uh at a premium um
even though like weste head grew up in
the in the Philly kind of Lal St Joe's
tree where that's not the way they
played but yeah I think they were a
little bit ahead of their time but but I
think you can balance it and run get
easy baskets quick threes I mean you'd
rather have a three in transition than
work 20 seconds to get one where it's
going to be more contested um it's not
always true but uh that's that I think
back then Dan we didn't because the
three came into college in ' 87 and we
didn't understand the asymmetrical
threat it was remember back then when
patino was at Providence and everybody's
like oh my God look at all the threes
they're shooting what they shoot 12 a
game you know now now you shoot 12 in
the first 10 minutes yeah and uh it's a
totally different game now and but it's
opened things up and and it's a little
bit more exciting game but I'll tell you
what like the the player the people our
age that are gone geez these big guys
they don't know how to play like they're
having to guard ball screens and recover
and their guarding multiple actions and
you're worri when they pick up a foul
holy cow like my biggest task was I had
to meet my assignment at the free throw
line and fight him for low post position
that was the end of it I never guarded a
ball screen in college but I go back to
that patino Providence team with Billy
Donovan I mean they that wasn't a great
team as much as it was it felt like it
was a system like he he had a system
before Nolan Richardson had a system but
you know that was defense but here was
patino I mean he was so far ahead of his
time with utilizing the three-point shot
as a
weapon he always has been in everything
he's probably along with bob Knight
maybe the best teacher of the game I've
come across uh but you know he's going
to look to what's his Advantage I mean a
lot of You Know Dan you've seen this as
much as I have a lot of coaches will
talk about how they want to play and
maybe not enough think about how we
gonna win doesn't matter how I want to
play how are we going to win with the
Personnel we have and patino's always
been at the Forefront of how we going to
win when you see Zion Williamson now
what goes through your
mind same thing that went through my
mind the first time I saw him is that
there's never been anybody like this on
a basketball floor and the only thing
that's kept him from being the um the
player among the players in the league
has been injured and when he's healthy
his numbers are ridiculous uh his
efficiency is a joke and he's freaking
Unstoppable and you know the only the
only other player I remember saying that
about uh that I've never seen anything
like this on a basketball floor is
Victor wanyama because at 74 he's doing
things that nobody's ever done at that
size and I'm not surprised he's maybe a
little bit surprised he's having that
much success this early but I'm not
surprised he's having success you know
you knew if he stayed healthy he was
going to come but but this early uh it's
been pretty remarkable I think and you
of course were a Lockdown Defender in
college how would you guard Victor W by
Yama uh I would start screaming for help
and uh soon as you got to the arena yeah
I don't I don't think I'd be in the game
very long if uh if I were but that's
kind of the thing I mean you know wait
minut you played against Samson though
didn't you well I was in the game when
Samson was there like that was my first
ACC game it was number we played number
one Virginia it was like late December
in uh or early December in 1983 82
8283 and uh I did a great defensive job
on Samson I held him to 36 points okay
and uh it was remark but and I felt
really bad about that I thought I need
to find something else to do because and
then two weeks later he had 40 against
Ohio State he was guarded by Clark
Kellogg and herp Williams and I thought
well maybe I don't suck as much as I
thought they had two players on them in
the had 40 are you are you at Duke's
practice now yeah they're they're
finishing up their shoot around then
Michigan State comes in then Kansas and
you're not going to get if coach Kay was
coaching Duke right now would would he
have a problem with you being on a zoom
call no uh no he wouldn't had a problem
coach Kay uh treated me as a broadcaster
much like as a player he didn't notice
me when I was in the
gym I said this when coach Knight died
that you did me a favor when you talked
to him one time and he wanted to know if
anybody I'm paraphrasing anybody Sports
Center new basketball and you mentioned
that I did and and it changed my
relationship with him uh up until the
very end uh I was in contact with
somebody who was close to him uh but I I
wanted to thank you again for for saying
that because a you were correct that I
did no
basketball uh but you know he he resp he
accepted me because of you uh kind of
validating that so I appreciate that
well he he accepted you because of you
not anything I said I mean it was just a
discussion he he didn't find too many
people at that time at the company that
he trusted um and on the basketball side
and I tried to talk him out of it that
there were and and you know you were the
one but it was it was not just
basketball knowledge Dan I don't mean to
blow smoke at you but it was it was
because of how trustworthy you are and
uh and so I'm not surprised you two had
a good relationship have fun uh thanks
for joining us my best Holly and Dan and
we'll be watching tonight always brother
thank you for having me that's Jay bis
he'll be on the call tonight so it's a
double header it's Duke in Michigan
State that's seven Eastern on the
mothership followed by Kentucky and
number one Kansas that's the United
Center in Chicago